[Music]
Bartis tyka old enough for you guys to
play hide-and-seek yes we've been
playing really where do you gets it
he gets the concept but he's not good
because yesterday
how's counting and then there's like
this fire hydrant and then he's hiding
but his eyes are over it as I'm walking
towards him you can see his eyes go how
the [ __ ] does you know where I am
he's getting it what about when he has
to find you oh look you find hi - good
he starts crying oh because he can't
find you can't find me yes oh I have to
like always hide but then like purposely
put like my toe out and then he goes
yeah you were teaching him to suck at
hide-and-seek you're teaching him really
poorly because he's gonna suck at
hide-and-seek and he's gonna need
somebody to have a limb out or you can't
find him oh my god
dad dad taught me how to play
hide-and-go-seek I was like why
hide-and-seek so hard in the real world
we honestly I'm thinking a minute but we
used to always play with Isaac - and we
would even play hide and seek in the
dark where we have his head laughs oh
[ __ ] it'd be like searching for each
other with the headlamps that's dope
yeah and then uh I was like the most
creative Oh in our old hell like the old
old house in Isaac's bedroom the
Landlord like he didn't have an actual
closet there so he got like this IKEA
kind of closet like it's standalone so
the top of it there was like a good like
gap between the ceiling and this
wardrobe and one time when we were
playing hide-and-seek
I actually climbed up on top and I was
hiding on top of the the Wardrobe and
they could not find me for sure though
just get so boring no when they can't
find you yeah every door Stevie come out
everyone I enjoy like every like inch
that they're looking in and like like
hearing their thought process like well
I don't know like I checked for mommy
over there like workers should be I
don't understand which is really he
rules did you guys play because I know
there's people that play were like after
the person stopped counting wherever you
hide that's over right so like you
thought you're stuck there that's your
station that I've also
where as the persons coming closer you
can slowly keep moving around and hide
in another place we never establish
rules but I don't know usually I think
we just stay below where we are but you
have to stay in the house right you
can't get in the car and drive away no I
wish I had that done they know that had
an extra lady you can hide in the garage
either hey come on dangerous or it was
too far away well in the other house
yeah just like why would you hide there
it's gross but my favorite hiding spots
are always the ones where it's like in
plain sight like at one time I have it
underneath the coat rack and we have so
many coats on there so I was like I'm
gonna stand up in this [ __ ] honest and
then it's just like you're just covered
up I don't even know just stand-in there
like basically plain sight like you're
not really even hiding but you just look
like you're just draped or like the
other testimony like there was a whole
bunch of blankets on the on the bed you
just like hid under the blanket yeah I'm
you been yeah just don't jump on the bed
please yeah by the way we're all adults
and we think this is a [ __ ] riot so
your brain doesn't change that much from
when you were kid this article here
about this girl this 18 year old who she
was playing a game of hide-and-seek with
her younger cousins who apparently she
doesn't normally play with but now since
everyone stuck at home and like they
were bored so she was like male we had
already like we can't go down in the
basement
we already hid underneath the bed and
then the closet so for her she thought
okay well I'll just hide in the washing
machine
no kids die like that this girl got
stuck where the fire department had to
come in and rescue her with the 18 year
old was in the 18 year old
top-loaders
how does she get stuck and they just
couldn't move her out I want to know - I
should get in I don't know how she got
stuck but I do know the way that they
were able to rescue her is she like this
inside holding the [ __ ] sinner and
drop the middle things that's why I
assume oh yeah they don't really go into
much haha but I do know that in order to
rescue her and get her out in the Fire
Department they were able to remove the
lid helped her get out but man that's
pretty funny the whole world's going
through like coronavirus scares and
stuff and this chick has to have
firefighters come to get her out of the
launcher that's amazing you know why cuz
she was bored as [ __ ] because the Quran
verse ya coronavirus in dude can you
imagine me the neighbors like you see
the firefighters come and you're like oh
[ __ ] they're infected yeah then you peek
through the window and you see this
[ __ ] you'll be funny if they get a
dolly and just take the whole washing
machine down the neighborhood this photo
kills me event like it's great finding a
photo when it's just a head popping out
head shouldn't be in there looking at
you - yeah like next time laundry basket
for sure she's just taking the bathroom
there might as well you already in there
just turn on the machine for a little
bit turn it on laundry hanging baskets a
sick place because then he put all
clothes we couldn't find him like I
tried that one time where I was like I
think I really can't find Isaac where
the hell is he and then you'd like try
to help us he'd be like mom you know my
and then till we know which room to look
in so finally I was like what the [ __ ] I
looked in the hamper but there was
clothes there so I was just like oh
you're not in there I always lost cuz I
started giggling when people got close
no
younger I used to always have to peace
so badly at the moment that I'm ready
I'm like why anxiety is you nervous yeah
that's when I started training my
bladder so you don't lose in
hide-and-seek
oh I have a field ladder now one of my
favorite things to do is one time know
where they're at
I try to torture them too so I just to
play with my cousin and then he was like
hiding in like a pile of blankets and
I'm like so I'm like I wonder if my
cousin is in these do you like to play
with your food before you eat it
yeah my cousin she sent me a picture of
her kid they were playing hide and seek
outside at the park right you ran behind
the pool and his head was like here but
his whole body was shown it was the
funny [ __ ] I don't know man too old to
be hiding there oh that's the truth
because that's Tycho would be hiding
like that right yeah well he was when
he's older - because you're not teaching
in our way yeah I like how he starts
crying because he can't find you that's
cute
the sickish is turning off the lights in
the whole house I used to go out with my
friends in my mid-twenties if we turn
off the lights in the whole [ __ ]
house and then walks up his mom's
watching me on TV but then you get a
flashlight and then one person hides and
everybody's got to look for its sake
that's like sardines you ever played
sardines no it's like reversed
hide-and-seek one person I enjoy it so
one person hides and everybody looks for
him right but when you find them you
hide - so slowly is one person left and
I remember my friends and I did this
when we were
really young and that's why it's our
Dean because everyone starts getting yes
hide in the same spot or huh
roughly in the same area so what we did
once was it was super scary right I
don't remember when it was like all the
teenager and we broke into like this
abandoned car dealership so it's a bunch
of [ __ ]
and you break in there with like a with
a flashlight and it's super scary
already because this stuff's throwing
about furniture [ __ ] brave so it's
super scary right and it's extra scary
because you kind of walk around and
slowly your friends start disappearing
yeah [ __ ] am I the last one and it's
super scary cuz than you and one friend
left you're like who's who's gonna be
literally every single person in that
situation I do not want to be any of
them like it's [ __ ] scary because
imagine you find a hiding you had you
find a hiding spot you're in this
abandoned [ __ ] building and now
you're just like oh my god they're gonna
kill me that's one of the funnest things
to do is that find like an abandoned
place with your friends and then go
there at night and then break in and
look at it and uhm mental institution
like a mental hospital in Downey and
this was during the day and you could
see like blood splatters on the [ __ ]
wall
yeah there was blood else actually or is
it like the kind of thing where people
break into it later to make it look
scarier maybe it could be but yeah like
now they actually have security there to
not allow people to break in but oh dude
think about it we could all play because
there's gonna be so many abandoned
businesses cuz the quran virus
oh no so many different places and play
hard and go see clean I'm so down yeah
yeah I'm staying home there's gonna be a
lot of bad in restaurants but later when
they open it back up and then all
everyone's out of business and then we
go yeah I can't wait they should have
like a hide-and-go-seek park that should
be a new business that's not so much
more fun than a [ __ ] escape room yeah
escape room should add a
hide-and-go-seek section or like element
like we can choose to go kind of like
airsofting but without the without the
pain true that's why I like laser tag
way better than airsoft thing why well
because I [ __ ] rule at it first of
all and also because it doesn't hurt
man right except for when like a little
[ __ ] kids beating me up and I did
that hurts pretty big-time because when
they wreck you and then they laugh at
you as you go by is it you think you can
run so much faster they they cut the
corners and they have no respect
I remember tagging like the last mile
wet there were these little kids that
would just stand next to you and keep
pulling the trigger on your chest over
and over so you just keep dying no
respect no respect from back well you've
got a little finger just pull away your
guns runs off when you get shot yeah
they wait for you that turned right back
on again they fill their time away yeah
just stay on you know respect their
hotheads yeah I never played laser tag
there's a place in my hammer
really Oh laser tag and go-karts guys go
whatever they reopen go-karts is my [ __ ]
like especially bumping the [ __ ] out of
kids and I just saying we played at
go-karts in Florida that one time that
was so fun yeah but dude can you imagine
if Bart sucks at laser tag dude no but
dude you're the guy right everyone's
like the pea Terry who's gonna probably
get the best shooting all the [ __ ] at
Bart's us it's gonna be so much fun to
make fun of him if I do suck at it cuz
like I [ __ ] rule but then everyone
kind of thinks it's probably bit but I'm
actually [ __ ] the Doge I believe you
I I'm a sharpshooter what have to
through their practice they suck because
they keep tashu you in the head but
there's no censor all right my wife is
looking for the real life [ __ ] doesn't
work you so fun I hope art songs will be
so funny
[Music]